was wäre wenn ich euch sagen würde dass
es in Europa ein Land gibt das mit der
Energiekrise richtig Geld verdient ein
demokratisches Land ein Mitglieder NATO
und eines das Gas und Öl in Hülle und
Fülle hat ja ihr liegt richtig ich
spreche von Norwegen dem Land der Lachse
und des Black Metal
ja Abschaltung des russischen Gases
richteten sich viele augenaufnahme wegen
einem Land das bis jetzt nach Russland
die zweitgrößte erdgasquelle Europas war
aber die Billionen Dollar Frage lautet
wird Norwegen Europa mit seinem Gas
retten können nun was auch immer der
Fall ist eines ist klar Norwegen wird
durch den Krieg noch reicher und das ist
viel wichtiger als die meisten denken
wenn noch wegen ist nicht nur wegen
seiner Rohstoffe von hoher Relevanz das
Land hat zusätzlich einen großen
Einfluss in der Geschäftswelt
obwohl der norwegische Staat nur etwas
mehr als 5 Millionen Einwohner hat
verfügt er über einen der größten
Investmentfonds der Welt den
norwegischen staatsfon eine Großteil der
Gewinne die der Staat mit fossilen
Brennstoffen erwirtschaftet wird in
Anlagen auf der ganzen Welt investiert
in Anlagen für erneuerbare Energien
Staatsanleihen Immobilien und Anteile an
den größten Unternehmen der Welt und das
könnte ganz erhebliche außenwirkungen
auf den Alltag aller Menschen haben
sogar im Bereich reichen die wir
vielleicht nie vermuten würden was hat
Norwegen zum Beispiel mit Fake News auf
Facebook zu tun oder mit
gewerkschaftskämpfen bei Amazon nein ich
bin nicht verrückt geworden am Ende
dieses Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen
warum alles was in Norwegen passiert aus
der Wirkungen auf die Wall Street auf
die ganze Welt und auch auf unser
tägliches Leben haben kann natürlich hat
es nicht an Leuten gefehlt die die
Norweger beschuldigt haben egoistisch zu
sein wie zum Beispiel der polnische
kriminister aber in Oslo weiß man nur zu
gut dass man nicht reich wird indem man
Geld verschenkt tatsächlich hat nur
wegen obwohl das Land ein großer
Ölproduzent ist damit die höchsten
Benzinpreise der Welt die Fragen die wir
uns heute stellen lauten also wie wirkt
sich der Krieg in der Ukraine auf
Norwegen aus und welche Auswirkungen
könnte wiederum Norwegen in diesem
Kontext auf die Weltwirtschaft haben
heute werden wir diese Fragen
beantworten und zwar wieso oft mit einem
schnellen Blick in die Geschichte
[Musik]
der norwegische Sonderweg
Norwegen ist derzeit der weltweit größte
Exporteur von Lachs und exportiert in
mehr als 100 Länder aber es wird
natürlich nicht nur Lachs exportiert
norwegen ist ein wichtiger Produzent von
Öl und Gas und obwohl wir alle den Lachs
so lieben sind es vor allem die
Kohlenwasserstoffe die 40 bis 70% der
norwegischen Exporte ausmachen und die
Norwegen zu einem der reichsten Länder
der Welt gemacht haben es ist nicht
einfach enorm wegen Öl zu finden in den
1960er Jahren wurden sie mehr als 200
Löcher bis sie ein Vorkommen fanden es
handelt es sich um das Ecovis Ölfeld und
ich weiß dass viele von euch jetzt
denken vor allem diejenigen unter euch
die Visual economik unseren Kanal der
sich mit Wirtschaft beschäftigt bereits
kennen ein Land entdeckt Öl da muss es
verdammt aufpassen es könnte vom Flug
der natürlichen Ressourcen getroffen
werden einem Fluch ja tatsächlich viele
Bodenschätze zu haben bedeutet nichts
zwingend dass man reicht wird in vielen
Fällen ist sogar Gegenteil der Fall aber
dieses Phänomen und seinen Hintergründe
erklären wir wie gesagt ausführlich in
einem visual economen Video dass ich
euch in der Beschreibung verlinken werde
aber
ist zum Glück für die noch Wege wieder
Russland noch Venezuela es ist ein ganz
besonderer Fall wieso nun hört zu
[Musik]
1972 gründete Norwegen die staatliche
Ölgesellschaft stadtall die heute equino
heißt im Jahr 2001 gab es tat all einen
Teil seiner Aktien an der Osloer und New
Yorker Börse aus aber die Regierung
hielt immer noch 81,7 % der Anteile im
Jahr 2007 kam es dann so eine Fusion mit
der Öl- und gasparade von NOx führenden
wasserkraftfahrzeuge zur Zeit besitzt
der norwegische Stadt knapp 68 % von
equinoa natürlich schüttet dieses
Unternehmen die wir dann aus die
größtenteils vom norwegischen Staat
eingezogen werden aber das ist nicht die
einzige Einnahmequelle Auslosung der
norwegische Stadt ist auch mit
Eigentümer viele Öl und gashelder des
Landes und die Steuern auf Gewinnen aus
der Erdölförderung sind extrem hoch vor
allem kann der Staat mehr als 75 % der
Gewinne behalten mit anderen Worten wenn
es in Norwegen um Öl geht ist der größte
Nutzer immer der Stadt
und die Frage ist was haben die Norweger
mit all dem Geld gemacht
nun 2019 gründete der Staat den
sogenannten Norwegian South einen
staatlichen Investitionsfonds geht
überschüssige Öl- und gaseinnahmen
investiert werden und warum fragt euch
vielleicht und weil dieser Staatsfonds
alle Krisen abfedert ölpreisverfall kein
Problem norwegen hat Investitionen alle
möglichen Vermögenswerte und zwar breit
gestreute Vermögenswerte die natürlich
nichts mit Öl zu tun haben dieser Form
wird übrigens von einer Abteilung der
nierenwegischen zentralen verwaltet aber
was viele von euch überraschen mag ist
die Tatsache ist der norwegische
Staatsform doch vor der Entscheider
Investment Corporation in den vor von
Abu Dhabi der größte Staatsform der Welt
ist darf man einen Blick auf diese Kraft
um euch eine Vorstellung von den
Dimensionen zu geben 2013 macht in der
Form umgerechnet
183% des BIP Norwegens aus und 2022
werden es bereits mehr als
225% BIP sein aber nicht nur das im
Gegensatz zu staatlichen Programmen
fragt euch vielleicht nun eigentlich
nicht sehr viel
weltweit fordert Norwegen etwa 2% des
verbrauchten Öl und 3% des Gases das
liegt weit hinter der Produktion von
Ländern wie den USA Saudi Arabien
Russland Kanada und Brasilien und vielen
anderen auch hier ist wieder ein
Vergleich angebracht im Jahr 2021
förderte saudi-arabi etwa 9 Millionen
Barrel Öl pro Tag die Vereinigten
Staaten 11 Millionen Kanada 4,7
Millionen Norwegen etwa 1,7 Millionen
solide also aber nicht Markt dominierend
allerdings ist nur wegen der drittgrößte
gasexporteur der Welt hinter Russland
und Katar
der Unterschied zu anderen Ländern liegt
darin dass Norwegen eines der wenigen
Länder ist das seine Gewinne aus Gas und
Öl konsequent in den Aktienmarkt
investiert und so sein erworbenes
Vermögen diversifiziert auf diese Weise
garantiert die Regierung praktisch die
Zukunft der Norweger wir alle wisst sind
Regierungen in der Regel netto Schuldner
das heißt die haben Schulden beim Rest
der Welt in den Vereinigten Staaten z.B
belaufen sich die Staatsschulden auf
etwa 93.000 pro US-Bürger in Italien
mehr als 50 000 $ in Spanien auch mehr
als 30.000 $ nun in Norwegen ist die
Situation vollkommen anders wisst ihr
wie viel jeder noch Wege an
Staatsschulden zahlen müsste nun
überhaupt nichts mit dem Geld aus dem
Staatsform könnten sie die gesamten
Staatsschulden des Landes abbezahlen und
ihm immer noch etwas 180
000 $ für übrig
[Musik]
sowohl die rechten als auch die linken
Parteien sind bis dadurch streng
konservativ mit dem Geld umgegangen und
habe es nicht vergeudet das ist in
anderen Ländern nur schwer vorstellbar
wo die Macht Übernahme auch bedeutet die
Beute zu teilen und stimmen zu gewinnen
die erste Entnahme von Geldern aus dem
Staatsmann erfolgte 2016 als 780
Millionen Dollar ausgegeben wurden um
einer durch die niedrigen Ölpreise
verursachten wirtschaftlichen Rezession
entgegen sogar wirken auf diese Weise
hat nur wegen dem Ölpreisschock kaum
bemerkt um es anders auszudrücken falls
es zu einem erneuten Ölpreise von käme
unter dem andere Förderländer sehr
leiden würden könnte Norwegen ist sich
leisten von einer solchen Krise nicht
einmal berührt zu werden aber wollt ihr
einen Fakt hören der wirklich euer
Gehirn explodieren lassen könnte nun im
Jahr 2021 verdiente die norwegische
Regierung etwa 30 Milliarden Dollar mit
der Ölförderung gemacht es zeigt sich
dass die durchschnittliche Rendite des
norwegischen staatsfon seit seiner
Gründung bei etwa 5,8 % liegt und das
bedeutet dass der Staat in einem
typischen Jahr mehr als doppelt so viel
an dem Gewinn ist und verdient wie eine
menüeinnahmen selbst mit anderen Worten
noch wegen ist bereits stärker vom Fonds
selbst abhängig als vom Öl das große
sparen das Norwegen vor der Ölkrise
rettet aber abgesehen davon dass
Norwegen sehr wohlhabend ist stellt sich
die Frage ob es die Rettung für ein
Europa sein könnte das auf ein Gasmarkt
diesen Punkt werden wir uns jetzt
ansehen
[Musik]
ist Norwegen die Errettung
Norwegen war schon vor dem Krieg in der
Ukraine ein wichtiger Partner der
Europäischen Union das Land exportierte
bereits 20% der europäischen
Erdgasversorgung und bis zum letzten
Jahr forderte Brüssel von Oslo die
Bohrungen in der Arktis aus ökologischen
Gründen einzustellen ist aber vor der
Brüssel das genau Gegenteil kostenlos
soll fördern wo auch immer es kann das
Ziel ist es nämlich russisches Gas durch
mehr Gas aus mehrere wegen und anderen
Ländern zu ersetzen und vorerst hat nur
wegen zu gesagt der exporter nach Europa
zu erhöhen um die Energiekrise zu
bewältigen nur wegen will die
kohlenwasserstoffproduktion bis 2023 und
6,8 % steigern wohlgemerkt diese Anstieg
kommt zu dem Anstieg hin zu der im Jahr
2022 zu verzeichnen ist in diesem Jahr
wird nur wegen 8% mehr Erdgasförderung
als 2021 insgesamt wird die Öl und
Gasproduktion mehr 2021 und fast 15 %
und im Jahr 2020 nur 6,8 % steigen das
heißt fast 23% mehr in nur zwei Jahre
falls ihr also Spaß
Verschwörungstheorien haben solltet
könnt ihr erraten welches europäische
Land am meisten von den russischen
gastanktionen und der Sabotage von
nordstream profitiert hat ganz genau
Norwegen
und ganz zufällig wurde am 1 Oktober
eine neue norwegische Gas in Betrieb
genommen die Pipeline heißt beltic und
hat bereits begonnen Gas von Norwegen
durch Dänemark nach Polen zu
transportieren die Ostsee-Pipeline wird
10 Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas pro Jahr
nach Polen Punkten bisher hat Norwegen
wie gesagt 20% des europäischen
Gasbedarf gedeckt aber in diesem Jahr
werden es jetzt ungefähr Folge und schon
25% sein und nächstes Jahr wird der
Anteil voraussichtlich noch höher liegen
außerdem sagt die norwegische Regierung
selbst das folgende die Europäer werden
Gas aus anderen Quellen als Russland
brauchen und unter diesen Gesichtspunkt
ist es schwer vorstellbar das ist viele
Orte gibt aus denen es natürlicher ist
in Europa weiterhin Gas zu importieren
als aus Norwegen für uns ist es wichtig
dass Sie wissen und wir Ihnen zeigen
dass Norwegen ein zuverlässiger
vertrauenswürdiger und ein langfristige
Energiepartner für Europa ist und ich
will nur hat bereits gesagt dass sie die
Produktion erhöhen werden aber wartet
ein Moment Norwegen verschafft Europa
zwar eine kleine Verschnaufpause von
aber das wird vorerst nicht die
ultimative Lösung sein
[Musik]
in Oslo reiben sie sich die Hände über
all die zusätzlichen Einnahmen und
wollen mehr Gas an ein bedürftiges
Europa verkaufen das Problem dabei
Norwegen kann seine Produktionskapazität
für Erdgas natürlich nicht über Nacht
verdoppeln so etwas dauert Jahre und
nicht nur das vor dem Krieg gab es sogar
einige die sagten dass Norwegen die
Förderung von Kohlenwasserstoffen schon
2.35 einstellen sollte okay das waren
die Grünen aber beachtet dass die
Arbeiterpartei quasi nur wegen
Sozialdemokraten die jetzt in der
Regierung sind zwar kein konkretes Datum
festgelegt hat aber dafür war dass
darüber verhandelt wird mit anderen
Worten es gab nicht viele Anreize in die
Öl und Gasindustrie des Landes zu
investieren und wir alle wisst ist es
unmöglich jahrelange des Investitionen
in ein paar Monaten umzukehren ein
weiterer Grund den Verkauf von Gas an
Europa erschwert hat sind die
europäischen wieder
verdampfungskapazität eine schnelle
Möglichkeit Gas zu liefern ist der Kauf
von verflüssigten Erdgas man muss da
nicht lange warten um neue Pipelines mit
Norwegen oder anderen Ländern zu bauen
aber die
regazifizierungskapazitäten in der EU
sind unzureichend Deutschland dass das
meiste Gas in der EU verbraucht hatte
vor dem ukrainekrieg keine einzige
regazifizierungsanlage und natürlich
verfügt auch Norwegen nicht über
ausreichende verflüssigungskapazitäten
den LNG muss ja erst verflüssigt und
dann wieder verdampft werden es braucht
also Kapazitäten an beiden Enden der
Transportkette kurz gesagt europa
braucht viel mehr Gas als Norwegen
kurzfristig anbieten kann in anderen
Politik Videos erklären euch genauer was
flüssig erdgas ist und welche
verschiedenen alternativen Europa hat in
der Energiekrise zu entkommen auf jeden
Fall diversifiziert Europa seine
gasbezüge und bereitet sich darauf
flüssig Erdgas aus verschiedenen Ländern
zu beziehen aber an dieser Stelle stellt
sich die große Frage sind die Norweger
eigentlich besonders hilfsbereit oder
steckt doch ein eigenes Interesse
dahinter oder gar eine dunkle
globalistische Agenda aufgepasst
[Musik]
das norwegische Monopoly
wie wir zu Beginn des Videos gesagt
haben verdient Norwegen eine Menge Geld
mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine aber was
bedeutet das nun für den norwegischen
Staatsform und die Weltwirtschaft haltet
euch fest denn die norwegische Regierung
erwartet dass sie allein im Jahr 2023
mehr als 130 Milliarden Dollar mit der
Ausbeutung von Erdöl und Erdgasvorkommen
verdienen wird und das ist noch nicht
alles im Moment werden die Einnahmen für
das laufende Jahr 2020 auf fast 120
Milliarden Dollar geschätzt und wisst
ihr wie die Norweger im Jahr 2021 also
vor putis Invasion der Ukraine
eingenommen haben tja etwas weniger als
30 Milliarden mit anderen Worten dank
des Krieges in der Ukraine wird Norwegen
in den Jahren 2022 und 23 das Equivalent
von 8 regulären Jahren an Einnahmen
erhalten und selbstverständlich wenn ein
großer Teil dieser Einnahmen in den
Stars von Fliesen und damit diesen zu
einem Investor mit noch tieferen Taschen
machen Norwegen besitzt bereits 1,3%
aller Aktien der Welt Unternehmen die
nestley Apple und Microsoft haben sie
norwegischen staatsbau als einen ihrer
größten Aktionäre soweit so
beeindruckend für ein so kleines Land
aber jetzt kommt er wirklich
interessante Teil ein Vorteil Aktionär
eines Unternehmens zu sein ist dass man
als solcher die Richtung des
Unternehmens beeinflussen kann wenn man
nur genügend Aktien besitzt nun bis vor
ein paar Jahren nahm der norwegischen
Staatsform keinen Einfluss auf die
Unternehmen in dir investierte sagen wir
er beschränkte sich darauf bestimmte
Arten von Unternehmen aus seinem
Portfolio auszuschließen im Wesentlichen
ging es um Waffenhersteller Produzenten
von bösen Kohlenwasserstoffen Tabak oder
Unternehmen mit zweifelhaften
Beziehungen zu Menschenrechten und das
alles tun die Investoren aus so
natürlich weiterhin
[Musik]
so hat der vor kurzem das kanadische
Unternehmen Bombardier und das
südkoreanische Unternehmen Hyundai Globe
ist auf einen Beobachtungsliste gesetzt
um sie möglicherweise zu verkaufen im
Fall von Hyundai war der Grund dafür
dass das Unternehmen angeblich
Schrottplätze in Pakistan und
bangladeshorts oder Arbeitsbedingungen
an Menschenrechtsverletzungen Grenzen
zumindest nach Angaben des vorn im Falle
Bombardier war der Grund der Verdacht
auf Korruption in verschiedenen Ländern
hat auch schon Kontroversen mit der
chinesischen Regierung gehabt er hat
alle Anteile an dem sportunternehmen die
Link veräußert alles offensichtlich
gegen die Menschenrechte in der
Regierung verstoßen haben
doch seit einiger Zeit hat sich die
Strategie des Klos ausgeweitet wir haben
uns von einem zurückhaltenden Eigentümer
zu einem aktiven Eigentümer entwickelt
am Anfang war die Idee einfach ein Stück
der globalen Finanzmärkte zu kaufen und
unsere Absicht war es nicht Einfluss auf
die Unternehmen zu nehmen es ist zum
Beispiel nicht mehr ungewöhnlich dass
dieser Fond im Voraus veröffentlicht wie
er bei Aktionärsversammlung über
bestimmte Themen abstimmen wird um Druck
zu erzeugen angeblich tun sie das um die
Unternehmensführung zu verbessern in
diesem Sinne stimmte der norwegische vor
2021 in sechs Resolution auf der
Facebook-Aktion erstversammlung dafür
dass Facebook transparenter sein und
eine bessere Berichterstattung vorlegen
soll unser Ziel ist es Unternehmen durch
eine bessere Governance zu stärken und
ihr langfristiges Risikomanagement zu
verbessern genau hier liegt jedoch der
potenzielle unruhigste Punkt ist der
norwegische Form von einem
geschäftlichen Fragen dazu übergeht
Druck auf Unternehmen auszuüben um mehr
kulturelle identitätsbezogen oder
politische Fragen zu klären mit anderen
Worten er Versuch den Unternehmen in dir
investiert norwegische Werte
aufzuzwingen beispiel gefällig 2022
stimmte der norwegische vor auf der
Aktionärsversammlung von Disney für
einen Menschenrechtsbericht und einen
Bericht über das Lohngefälle und etwas
ähnliches geschah dann auch bei Amazon
[Musik]
norwegen hat sich auf die Seite der
Amazon Beschäftigten gestellt die eine
Gewerkschaft gründen wollten auf eine
Aktionärsversammlung stimmt in Norwegen
gegen die Interessen von Jeff Bezos für
das Recht auf Tarifverhandlungen am
Rande sei erwähnt das Norwegen in diesem
Fall die Abstimmung verloren hat und das
unter anderem deshalb weil die
Beteiligungen des vor an Unternehmen in
der Regel relativ klein sind aber wenn
jemand so viel Geld ist wieder noch die
Straße sondern findet er natürlich im
mindestens gehört und eine erste Stimme
kann natürlich zu einem Trendsetter
werden viele andere Fonds und Aktionäre
könnten beschließen sich ihr
anzuschließen um es auf den Punkt zu
bringen Norwegen ist an der Börse wie
das beliebteste in der Schulklasse das
tanzt und nicht nur das wenn nötig
könnte dieser Frau auch größere Anteile
an bestimmten Unternehmen kaufen um sie
stärker beeinflussen zu können ihr könnt
euch sicherstellen dass ihr mit mehr als
1000 Milliarden Dollar in eurem
Investitions Portfolio praktisch alles
machen können was ihr wollt ein anderes
Beispiel du Norwegen ist nicht nur eines
der reichsten Männer der Welt sondern
auch eines der egalitärsten und genau
diese potenzialmodell versuchen sie
durch Beteiligungen in Unternehmen
einzubringen wisst ihr eigentlich wofür
sich Norwegen besonders stark einsetzt
ganz genau die Gehälter von Managern
Norwegen übt seit Jahren Druck auf
Unternehmen aus die hohen Gehälter ihrer
Manager zu senken und das bedeutet vor
allem eines der norwegische staatswort
könnte sich zu einem Albtraum für sie
aus entwickeln der größte staatsbau der
Welt stimmt gegen die geplante
Vorstandsvergütung von
fscook deshalb überraschen Schlagzeilen
die diese nicht und die Gehälter von
Managern könnten nur der Anfang sein die
norwegische Einflussnahme könnte in
vielen anderen Initiativen kumulieren
sagen wir einfach das Norwegen von
notfalls als politische Waffe einsetzen
könnte in die einen oder in die andere
Richtung
[Musik]
dieses Jahr kündigte der voran dass es
ein gesamtes russisches Vermögen
auflösen wird wir reden hier von 2,8
Milliarden Dollar das ist keine große
Summe wenn wir sie mit den Investitionen
vergleichen die sie in anderen Ländern
haben aber Taschengeld ist es auch nicht
gerade und über je mehr Geld der Frau
verfügt desto mehr Einfluss hat er
logischerweise auch wenn also eines klar
ist dann dass die riesige Geld Flut die
jetzt in das Land der Fjorde fließt
diesen Einfluss wahrscheinlich noch
merklich vergrößern wird es gibt Leute
die den norwegische Staatsoper für sein
Verhalten schafft kritisiert haben warum
weil die Verfolgung politischer oder
ideologischer Interessen bei
Investitionen zu Rendite Einbußen führen
kann und das könnten schlechte
Nachrichten für die Norweger selbst sein
aber wenn wir schon über Kritik sprechen
auch Norwegen selbst wurde wegen seiner
hohen Einnahmen aus dem Krieg stark
kritisiert der polnische Premierminister
hat darauf hingewiesen dass Norwegen
direkt vom Krieg profitiert und das Land
aufgefordert diesen neuen Reichtum mit
der Ukraine zu teilen übrigens haben wir
über den norwegischen Staatsform ein
eigenes Video gemacht falls ihr also an
mehr Hintergrund und interessanten
Geschichten über ihn interessiert seid
liegt auf den Link den ich euch in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe und jetzt
kommen wir zu den Fragen an euch wird
Norwegen es schaffen mehr Gas zu fördern
um Europa vor der Energiekrise zu retten
wie immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion
zu diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht dabei
auch das gelernt habt falls ja gib uns
bitte ein Like mit euren Freunden und
vergesst nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen und
keines unserer Videos zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns hält
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]